as I said we have two marvelous
panelists here tonight vs Arun shalam is
a very well known person to you as he is
on the Carnegie Mellon campus now he's
the founder and chairman of the Center
for the Study of science technology and
policy or C stumped as it's called in
Bangalore in the next chapter of what
has been a really illustrious career he
as you probably know served a scientific
advisor to the defense minister of india
for more than 10 years and he served as
head of the Defence Research and
Development Organisation India's largest
rd institution we're very proud also
that he served as a professor at
carnegie mellon for many years and still
is a professor at carnegie mellon but
now is resident here in bangalore
leading see step which is a very
important undertaking providing policy
advice technically based policy advice
in energy and environment and other
topics please join me in welcoming and
thanking a room for being part of this
dinner professor retail ah runo you have
to have to get to work now you got to
come up here and while he is let me
introduce our other panelists Pradeep
Khosla is dean of carnegie mellon's
carnegie institute of technology
engineering college we've kept the name
purdy Carnegie Tech is kind of
engineering college he's been Dean since
2004 he serves as the Phillip and Marsha
dial university professor he's done many
many things at Carnegie Mellon besides
serving as a truly extraordinary Dean he
was the founding director of Scilab our
major computer security center which has
been a world leader he was head of an
ECE department before taking on the
deanship he's very well known in India
in the US and around the world and was
elected recently to the National Academy
the highest honor and engineer can
Eve in the world ladies and gentlemen
pretty coastal
so I'm going to offer up some questions
to our panelists to get things started
but I want you to be thinking about
questions you'll have for them because
at some point not too far to this I'm
going to turn it over to you and invite
you to offer questions let me start with
you a room I thought particularly a good
topic for you to talk on one of just
many that you could is the solar mission
a very ambitious undertaking that India
has launched solar energy can have as
big potential here in particular
generating electricity from solar energy
would be as a very promising thing but
also a challenging thing and your
perspective on the prospects for this
and the challenges of doing it in India
would be valuable please thank you doing
i think we produce less than three
megawatts today and that to us a--
photovoltaics somewhere in the south and
some in the north but what our
government has set is by 2030 little our
little earlier we will be having about
20,000 megawatts is something
unbelievable and fifty percent from
solar thermal and other fifty percent
from the solar photovoltaic and it has
offered many opportunities of you know
differing some of the costs involved in
setting up the plant and also the cost
of the power but this is going to be
most challenging one because well
photovoltaics one is slightly familiar
and also we are manufacturing a lot of
sort of solar photovoltaic for export to
other countries this would be the first
time that we would be setting it up and
we are first ensuring that the solar
thermal can have a place in India and
the couple of regions are now being
identified one is Rajasthan which its
apparent nearly sunny country and also
sue
cuts region and also Ladakh so it's
going to be a challenge for us how to
make the solar thermal competitive
because our analysis shows that the cost
of per kilowatt hour what we call a unit
here is running to about 17 rupees to 20
rupees the government is willing to
subsidize up to almost 13 rupees so
where are we going to find the rest of
the money and the industry Lisa are
saying it we are not interested unless
you bring the cost of this down
significantly how we're can we bring
that down and what technology would that
be solar thermal by parabolic trough or
would that be a tower or would that be a
disk dish one these are the challenges
this one is far more challenging because
of the Stirling engine problems but also
provides an opportunity but as I as far
as i know but twenty corporations are
now working seriously on bringing trying
to bring solar thermal to the country
and everybody talks about the gramercy
junction near bakersfield in california
where they have been producing
generating about 300 megawatts whether
we will be able to do that it depends
but right now the jury is out and solar
thermal but solar photovoltaic I think
we are quite keen that we can manage it
right now because it also absorbs a
diffuse light unfortunately in India the
beam him the beam light is little less
than in the United States and Spain and
diffuse light is higher and in solar
photovoltaic is forgiving that but not
so much on solar thermal these are some
other challenges I'm going to ask you
later or so bad about nuclear which is
another mat now I mean but you have a
lot to say on this and it's important
that this audience hear it and this is a
real expert but let me just ask Pradeep
a question get him talking I made
reference in my introduction in my
remarks that Pradeep has been a leader
of our efforts in creating environmental
and energy research topics and one I'd
like you to talk about in particular
Pradeep that you've created is the
institute for advanced energy systems
the collaboration with
universities and with the National
Energy Technology lab this is very
exciting Thank You Jerry it's great to
be here great to see so many people
before I to talk about the Institute let
me just make at least a kimono to
comments about the infrastructure needed
for doing energy right in any country
and that has to be more integrative
education and we'll come back to that at
Carnegie Mellon we followed this for I
don't know 50 60 70 years long before
the wig was there and that has been our
motto since I think Andrew Carnegie
sword Carnegie Mellon and one of the
great things we did then and not not
then but about 30 years ago was keep
within the College of Engineering of
school department of engineering and
public policy so when we realized that
energy was going to be big that this was
before Obama was elected about two years
before he was elected it was clear that
that's the energy had to become big we
built what we think of as a
public-private partnership a partnership
between Carnegie Mellon and any tln ET l
stands for National Energy Technology
Laboratory which is mainly a fossil
fuel-based laboratory so all the work
that is for fossil fuels which is called
right including a clean coal and to make
it better yet because being a small
school we didn't have all the
capabilities we brought in University of
Pittsburgh which is our neighbor and
West Virginia University which is also a
neighbor slightly far away and this
point is relevant I say this because in
the Indian context I hope when you go
back you get at least one or two ideas
from here universities don't quite work
with each other the way we within the US
do where we compete during the day and
work together during the night and even
when we work together it is a very
competitive process if three of us are
working together we are competing with
the other 95 and combination keeps on
changing so that needs some really
spectacular work so this consortium now
is focused on alternative fuels so it
focuses on everything except for
always fuels and it has already made a
big impact on the whole idea of this
consortium is to make Pittsburgh and
Carnegie Mellon any ownership Pittsburgh
and West Virginia University the hub for
energy related research in the country
and most likely in the world so one of
the problems we are looking at we're
looking at problems like solar energy
generation wind power generation
integrating multiple sources of energy
on the same grid which is a slightly
simplistic way of calling smart graph
this is a way to explain smart grids if
somebody throws the words the two words
smart grid at you what it means is one
grade where you have normal power
generation solar electrical like thermal
whole sort of alternative power
generation all on the same grade and
seamless to use the user or the consumer
of this energy so the key thing here is
that the typical power plant a
coal-fired power plant just runs more or
less costly all the time the problem
with wind-generated electricity is
sometimes the wind doesn't blow the
grids that purdy was talking about don't
like that so you need a way to manage
these kind of supplies that come on and
go off that's the idea the smart grid
and Carnegie Mellon engineering / deep
has built one of the world's leading
groups in this in developing the kinds
of modeling techniques and decision
making methods to control a grid when
they're dealing with these kinds of
solar and wind sources a room I would
like you to talk about nuclear power let
me just set it up by saying I read
recently that just like with the solar
mission the government is called for an
increase of something like a factor of a
hundred in the amount of nuclear
generating capacity in India and be in
answering in responding to that or
giving us your thoughts on it I'd like
you to say something more about see step
also and maybe like to introduce Rahul
also who's in the audience who please
I work for about 10 years in Delhi I I
work for five prime ministers and about
11 defence ministers they were changed
they were Chinese changing more rapidly
than I was so then I thought that was a
good time for me to go out and teach
some place where I could be still I I
would be changing and that it provided
an unique opportunity until then in
Delhi of course I was helping government
enunciate policies i was helping the
government right policies but that's
kind of a in the trade you pick up on
the way essentially i was a technologist
carnegie mellon changed me all that the
first time when i went there and the
engineering and public policy Granger
said our own welcome to Carnegie Mellon
would you like to give a talk on
technology in the economic growth so
just overnight I became a student
cramming the night so that I could tell
the students the next day hoping they
don't ask any difficult questions but uh
when I returned from the United I I
thought I went there for two years but
when I just looked at the calendar and
diary it was 10 years and it was time to
come back when I returned I thought that
this is something very exciting it's
exciting because in our country their
technology is done by a group of
scientists and their technologies and
policy is done okay you're the number
one and the ministries were absolutely
no clue of the pluses and the minuses of
the technologies their private fears the
public postures all these things are
missing so I thought why not we are
tempted and I had a very active
encouragement from Granger and Jerry
also visited us last time saying that
why don't you start building an
organization so very similar to what
engineering and public policy is in a
sense it's like let's say a mini or
micro or incorporation kind of thing but
the growth we didn't expect it would be
that spectacular because three years
back we started and I'm happy here them
collides here the SSM foundation mr.
shiv nadar came and gave me a first
endowment and said don't waste it on
drinks he said and and I'm happy to say
that at that time we had about three
employees Rahul was still then in
Pittsburgh and about a budget of about
two crores today we have about 50 with a
very large and I think it has the
largest number of Carnegie Mellon PhDs
about six of something and today I think
our our we are about 50 people and with
a budget little more than 17 crows and
growing fast so this growth or is made
possible because of the enormous
exposure I had the advantage that Carnac
Mel and I had was the seamless movement
I was a professor in three departments
but got only one salary I think I must
have gone out and I was giving courses
in two and doing research on the third
and I I really found that there was no
difficulty at all in communicating
between computer scientists engineered
material scientists and public policy
people and it is this that brought me
first I started looking at our Indian
nuclear energy program I started my
career working in atomic energy in india
i was a darling of the establishment at
that time but then I started saying
asking is it really true that we can
manage all these things and the first
PhD work of that was done by rahul tanya
orderly get a proble and he he did a PhD
at Carnegie Mellon and brought the
attention saying that it will take much
longer in thorium and which our
government accepts today and the
government's agreement turn there with
the United States first and with the
rest of the world was also energized by
our pressing argument you cannot build a
nuclear power in the country without
becoming a member of the world community
of nuclear power producers simply saying
that I can be I can be you cannot
because our uranium resources are so
limited it's about 10,000 megawatts and
you can after building 10,000 megawatts
saying that thorium is coming is without
30 40 years away plutonium is one
possibility
and today you might have known the two
reactors the Russian reactors and
coutinho Lamar both are thousand
megawatt first time we are having a
thousand megawatt reactor and when
prayer when Prime Minister Putin came I
think we have signed for six more so
that means in a single step we are more
than doubling over capacity but a very
exciting thing that next time i will
take Jerry to show that he is that's
taking place not too far from Chennai is
we are running a fast reactor fast
breeder reactor and we are run it for
without any incident for the past 15
years and we plan to build one very very
quickly and it's already being built and
Indian future is going to be light water
reactor is coming from united states
soviet russia the France Germany and so
on and also the fast breeder reactors
that's coming out of the Indian
technology so it is exciting again being
the teacher breeder reactors or nuclear
power plants have produced more fuel
than they use it sounds like magic but
through the nuclear fission process and
to have a plant that's been operating 15
years is quite extraordinary the next
without it yeah which the Japanese can't
say or the French either great well let
me see if there are questions at this
point if not I'll keep asking them
questions I got plenty of them haroon
yeah use your mic devil yes you no no I
was pretty excited I'm our own site here
pretty excited on the solar mission
because I besides what I do co British
Telecom I'm on the boards of some
companies deeply interested in this
particular space and I actually believe
what you're saying which is that solar
thermal is going to be the answer for
this country there's a company I'm
associated with called Acme telly power
I I don't know whether you've heard of
them or not I'm presume we have we've
done a few good things a few bad things
no no we were just for the record we
were too ambitious in terms of thinking
where the cost could come down I think
we probably distorted a few things but I
think it's all recovered with the new
crc policies but just to for the
audience the technology which this
Indian company is coming out with just
this young company called Acme is run by
a 35 year old guy he's not an IIT just
for the record Freddie and it's come up
very well in the started about six years
ago capital of 30 lakhs turn over last
year was 2000 crores it's in the energy
efficiency business and they've invested
in a company in the u.s. called East
solar with Bill Gross and I've visited
bill there in fact bills also coming to
speak at panihati and and that
technology is at our technology but
using mirrors and I mean I love that
particular thing personally because I'm
from the IT side and know nothing about
energy nothing about these things but it
uses small mirrors not huge parabolic
mirrors something and it uses IT to
simulate a parabola aha so it's got rid
of the complexity of parabola etc so I
think those kind of technologies for our
country are really going to be the right
ones because we do have huge amount of
IIT capability here there will be no
imports because you make all those
mirrors the IT is fungible and we've got
sunlight diffused sunlight or whatever
it is but at scale I do believe that
that's the right answer for us the
Spanish government issued have a
statement of assessing technologies they
said the future is with the tower
technology except they said the
technology risk is very high so one has
to manage both and we can talk later
about some other technologies
involve because we have done a very
detailed study I'm over we'd be quite
happy to share their our listens to you
absolutely aware and the reason is I
mean again the thing is I'm talking of
in terms of risks by and large most
Indian companies are known to be very
risk-averse this little young company
has invested 30 million dollars in that
company it's taken that risk and I do
believe that unless we take those risks
we can't reach the kind of result that
we want it's a very active area of
research and commercialization and are
going to be lots of things that fail but
there are a lot of things being tried it
somewhere to succeed I think I'll have
huge impact other questions or comments
yes please I'm the I'm it's adam am the
chief representative of the League of
Arab states mission in Delhi we work in
what is called the endo Arab cooperation
forum including scientific cooperation
and it's not all the Arab countries are
oil producing countries so some of them
are still underdeveloped and back to
India as we have seen in Copenhagen in
the discussion what saved the
last-minute agreement with the US was
the four countries which is including
India besides Brazil and China when
there was no consensus among all the
member states and more than hundred and
ninety countries of members of the UN so
I think what we heard today is very
important and I don't have a questions
just comment I mean and what also
current Mellon University is doing with
India is very useful and we look to have
it as an example also in the cup in the
indoor up cooperation thank you very
much thank you go ahead pretty but I go
ahead why I just wanted to just
underscore one thing obviously the area
of cooperation international cooperation
is absolutely essential and we know that
to be the case for climate change in
dealing with climate change and
Copenhagen is the latest incident that
but you raise an interesting point about
international cooperation in areas like
new technology development and i have to
say i'm not even i'm not aware of any
ticker role at the UN or other potential
agencies are playing and if someone is
be interested in here about the co-head
pretty yeah i wanted to talk about you
made several comments and embedded in
your comments were some potential
questions that i interpret it right so
pick up on what Jerry was NJ was telling
you all that we're going to think about
an India strategy in the very near
future I think if you look at the
education system in India which by the
way i think is spectacular no wonder
everybody from many parts of the world
want to come now especially now having
said that it still has some weaknesses
so for example if you look for a top
program in environmental engineering
whether it be here all of you or a
quality you would see some things and
better than the chemistry department or
some things i'm better than some very
siloed apartment and i think what we
need to think about is integrated
programs in india specializing in power
systems life I mean environmental
engineering or energy engineering that
kind of bring together a fundamental
knowledge in one branch of engineering
and training you are the masters of the
phd level to bring together multiple
branches and I say this because in the
US we just start a program in masters in
energy
systems engineering where you can be
chemical engineer electrical mechanical
doesn't matter you come in and by the
time you graduate you have an
understanding of solar power even
understanding of geothermal power does
it make sense or not are you have an
understanding of wind power nuclear
power by the traditional fossil fuels
and all connected amazingly by this
layer called IT which is the integrative
layer so it cannot be so I T we in India
use it as the final outcome but where
the world is going right now i T is an
integrative layer that connects multiple
things together and I think we have to
have some more domain expertise so I
think you will see you'll find us or
people in India and doing more
integrative education and saying this
because Carla can hear it and change SSN
to create a program masters program and
energy systems engineering job and this
is the kind of thing we'd love to try to
help Indian higher education to adopt I
we're working on that one last question
yes Derek yes Darren Reza alam of
architecture I mean let me just add he
just moved to Delhi three weeks ago yeah
the beginning of the month beginning of
the month right after Holly and puri is
so take a look at his face and stay
connected to him Derek just in terms of
energy with the global energy
consumption being about forty percent by
our buildings and that's just during the
operation not accounting for the energy
used to construct them what what are our
opportunities or larger opportunities as
we continually build larger cities and
develop more to get towards you know
carbon neutral buildings and truly
understanding the impact of our
footprints and such
not sure really where the question is
are such but it's just a sort of an
underlying thought with the work i do
but in terms of understanding this idea
of energy the idea of LEED buildings the
idea of building smart which I'm
actually pursuing to bring to India so
as ways of us to sort of understand one
of the largest consumers of energy in
the world well let me respond from a
Carnegie Mellon perspective and my
colleagues can add if they would and you
know this but I'd like everybody else to
know and I'm take your comment as a sort
of a set up to say these things one of
areas when you get to talk about up to
now that Carnegie Mellon is very strong
and has been a leader in is in green
building technology the School of
Architecture from which Taryn graduated
was been one of the pioneers in that
field we have a group of faculty led by
Vivian loftness Volker heart cough and
Stephen Lee the current head of the
school who have created centers and
projects and coursework all built around
this I think it's generally a given that
through early modest efforts at
conservation and more efficient
buildings we could save a great deal of
energy globally and if we put our minds
to it adopted some of the more advanced
building approaches that our colleagues
the carnegie mellon have been developing
we can save huge amounts indeed one of
the projects that are faculty been
advancing though it's still a concept
because we have been able to find the
money to do it is something they call
building as power plant the idea being
you create a building so efficient that
as such as carbon neutral actually
generates more energy than it uses
through the intelligent use of materials
and new energy sources like fuel cells
or energy and energy generation sources
like fuel cells it's a very exciting
prospect it's quite doable current
technology but putting it together not
unlike what her room
saying about solar thermal you can do it
but can you do it had a kind of cost at
a price point where clients will buy the
building or people will adopt the
technology that's the key and that's
where we need more innovation and that's
what currently melts working on any last
comments anything they're actually of
the Ministry of Power has a Bureau of
energy efficiency in the country and
what we are working with them is to see
that whether we can reduce energy
consumption in many of the areas for
instance that some of the Indians cement
plants are outstanding some of the best
in the world and some others are perhaps
the worst in the world so what we are
trying to see is other methods of
integrating it in helping each other
build upon this the energy efficiency is
our low hanging fruit and that's what we
want to get in first we'll just make one
comment so I think you're a good point
where energy consumption and building is
about forty percent but the class of
buildings we need to worry about I think
our data centers the energy consumption
in data centers is going to far exceed
the energy consumption in this power
that we are seeing we're already seeing
for example LED lighting being
commercially available and viable and I
think about less than ten years you
would not find any of these fluorescent
lamps it would all be LED lamps that are
consuming ten percent of the light and
have like thirty or forty percent more
longevity right so it's the data centers
that worry about and there is a great
research project we're working with some
of the leading cooling supplying cooling
supplier companies to create energy
efficient data centers where they're
using half the energy of normal data
centers thank you can I just make one
more comment if you have time we don't
have time but make it any other thank
you just a thought which came to me
listening to all this I wasn't really
aware that amount of work which CMU is
doing in the space so thank you very
much for that but completely different
are in terms of research going on CS
India something like seventy eighty
percent of our infrastructure is not
built yet so if we were to copy the
standards of what the West is which we
want to aim at I think the world doesn't
have enough resources for that so I
certainly believe that you know with the
kind of design which we do here because
we are engineers design in a constrained
world energy we've all read energy
constraint we've never had a good supply
of energy we are design everything in a
very constrained way unlike in a very
free energy wave which the West which
the West does right so if you're looking
at new technologies coming out so maybe
a collaboration between us and India in
terms of designing stuff for the whole
world actually will come out of this
place this is my personal see I I think
that's a very perceptive comment that
applies to a lot of things oh man
shouldn't get into this I I have control
of the podium so I could say this and
you can't answer me but I there a lot of
companies based in the developed world
or thinking hard about products for
India what company is it and what
they're finding of course is that
products developed for the American
market you can't just take them and
apply them especially when talking about
infrastructure and things like that to
the Indian market so they're busily
trying to redesign and adapt I believe
though what you say which is that once
that's done you'll have something that
the world will one not just into you and
it'll be more energy efficient it'll be
much lighter on on the planet just by
virtue of the kinds of constraints in
India has that and will you will all
benefit from that and it's a great
opportunity for you to sort of reverse
globalize if you will let me conclude
with a couple of things first of all my
expertise is water
and this topic here is green leadership
and we haven't talked about water at all
and water is an enormous problem
worldwide and nowhere bigger than in
India there are simply too many people
in India they don't have access to
secure potable water supplies and that
shouldn't be certainly the technology
and the know-how exist this has been the
case for decades people die because of
bad water in India and they shouldn't
and this is something that your
government has to get on top of em I
know you know they don't need to be told
this and they know that but it's a
source of great anxiety for me and
please join me in thanking our marvelous
panelists for their excellent